لاول مره وعلى بعد امتار من ساحه الحرب في
اوكرانيا تجري الفرقه 101 الجويه
الامريكيه وتحت مظله الناتو تدريبات
ومنورات عسكريه في رومانيا الفرقه 101
المحموله جوا او كما تلقب بفرقه النسور
الصاخبه الامريكيه كانت قد اعادت انتشارها
باوروبا لاول مره منذ 80 عاما تحديدا بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه لتبدو هذه المره
اقرب من اي وقت مضى من الحرب في اوكرانيا
الفرقه القتاليه هذه اتخذت من قاعده للجيش
الروماني وهي قريبه من البحر الاسود مركزا
لها ونقطه انطلاق لاي عمليه عسكريه محتمله
للدفاع عن دول النيترو في حال اي تهديد
سينما الخاسره الشرقيه للحلف
نشر هذه القوات في رومانيا يعد بمثابه
تحذير لموسكوكا جزء من تعهد الرئيس
بالدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضي نيته واجراء
تدريبات مشتركه هو وسيله لضمان استعداد
الحلفاء في جنوب شرق اوروبا للبقاء على
الخط
4700 جندي من القوه 101 المحموله جوا تم
نشرهم في اوروبا خصوصا برومانيا لتعزيز
الجناح الشرقي لحلف النيته وتامينه من اي
هجوم الروسيه المحتمل مستقبلا نشر الفرقه
101 هذه لها اهداف ابعد من اوكرانيا
وروسيا فهي الفرقه الامريكيه تستخدم البحر
الاسود للتدريب على دفاع الساحلي وهي
مهاره وهي مهاره مفيده اذا فكرت الصين
بغزه تايوان وهي جزيره وسط البحر لكن
التركيز الان وفقا المعلن هو مراقبه الحرب
باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
5 6 7
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]